at the foot of lothric castle an old
path still runs below the tower in the
undead settlement it was used to
transport sacrifices to the cathedral of
the deal you should see red leads if
you've the stones so we're traveling
along the road of sacrifices towards the
Cathedral of the deep and Aldridge st.
of the deep
apparently lies within Aldridge is a
Lord of cinder and a Lord of cinder is
someone who has linked the fire in a
previous age they were so mighty and
powerful that they could link the fire
and extend the age of flame but that was
in a past age and now alongside the
other Lords of cinder Aldridge has been
resurrected to link the fire once more
but this time he's hiding from his duty
his run away to his home at the base of
lothric castle the crestfallen knight
speaks of sacrifices that were
presumably going to Aldrich because
Aldrich is referenced as a devourer of
men so this path to Aldrich this road of
sacrifices I think it was used a long
time ago because this path is now
crawling with Cove Ian's creatures who
are these deformed beasts men who we
learn more about from their weapons and
they have a fascinating little story the
storytellers staff reveals that the
casters are heretic all storytellers who
share tales of the painted world two
forlorn souls however the tellers
themselves they're also wretched beings
with no place to go The Cove Ian's with
the great knife are named as unwanted
they are guided by the storytellers and
they wield this big old knife that is
used to intimidate foes but all it does
is reveal how afraid they are themselves
because they fight like animals backed
into a corner
some wield great corvy incites which
directly reference priscilla of the
painted world and there are so many
similarities between these creatures and
priscilla if you remember Priscilla was
a crossbreed between a dragon and most
likely a lord or a God she was locked
away in a painting where she speaks
affectionately of all the other unwanted
beings that were locked away with her
this land is peaceful its inhabitants
kind so by mimicking Priscilla's
weaponry and by telling her stories it's
really clear that these creatures admire
or maybe even worship her because these
are unwanted
lost creatures and Priscilla is the
champion of the deformed and the
unwanted and rejected if you drop off
the bridge here you'll find this hidden
little alcove this cave that hides
morn's ring and a divine Braille tome
and in episode three we actually rescued
the two characters that these items are
associated with Aegon of Kuran and his
captive arena so considering how close
this little cave is and the items within
it I really imagine these two sitting
here resting on their journey to their
next destination Aegon is night of
Corrine and mourns ring is a ring that's
given two nights of Kareem to boost
miracles the character named morn who we
haven't met yet and we might never meet
him he's described to be this
high-ranking apostle within Kareem's
church system and he labored with the
goddess kayfa to provide comfort to the
suffering kayfa has been referenced
before she's really frequently mentioned
in Dark Souls 2 descriptions as this
goddess of Tears who's known as a
compassionate being that is with us in
times of tragedy although there's some
item descriptions that say that she's a
demoness that guides us towards
misfortune and finally we clear the road
of sacrifices and below us is the
crucifixion woods but before that we
come across a and kindled
who is coming through here much in the
same way that we are and that's
something I missed in blood-borne Dark
Souls is very much about meeting
characters who really inhabit the same
world that you do and empathize with the
same struggles oh hello how do you do I
am an array of astora on kindled like
you
this is Horus a friend and travelling
companion and you too in search of the
Lords of cinder we are well along the
road of sacrifices below us is the
crucifixion woods
beyond the flooded woods lies fair and
keep home of the undead Legion further
yet is the Cathedral of the deep we seek
the Cathedral home of the Grim Aldrich
we may go our separate ways now but we
are both seekers of Lords the next time
we cross paths one may find the other in
a time of need may the flames guide your
way so anri of astora is female here
right but if you play as a female
character then she'll be a man we sink
the cathedral home of the Grim Aldrich
you'll understand why this is in a later
episode I promise I can't wait until
April 12th when everyone has this game
and when I can invade you guys as of
this date only press and streamers have
access to the English PC version and
while the current early access system is
this complete mess it's completely
screwed up that the game is out early
like this I just can't help but cover it
early I'm sorry
making videos is half the fun for me I
can't resist one good thing did come out
of it though I was the first to kill PvP
streamer pvp vicent so that was fun I
mean it was fun for me I don't know if
it was fun for him but uh he gets me
back for it later so it's okay back at
the shrine we made series of the sunless
realms you're a nun kingdoms aren't you
I am serious of the sunless rounds
former servant of the divinity duties we
each bare but once duty is a solitary
affair I doubt we have much to gain from
fraternization blessing of the moon upon
your journey she certainly fits the bill
as a blade of the dark moon and the
sunless realms could well be a reference
to an Orlando and the illusion of
sunlight that gwyndolin projected upon
it all that time ago but that remains to
be seen and remains to be confirmed back
in the woods we take out the giant enemy
crab which you'll have to take out
fairly quickly otherwise it can actually
bury back beneath the ground and come up
again with full health one of them drops
the great swamp ring which boosts
pyromancy and reminds us that pyromancy
is supposedly born of the chaos flame
nearby is the conjurer set and a tome
that teaches us ancient pyromancies so
let's have a talk about pyromancy if
you're rusty on your Dark Souls law
remember that the chaos flame was
created long ago by the witch of izalith
the witch tried to create a flame that
could replace the fading first flame so
that the light of the world could be
restored but everything went wrong and
instead the flame consumed her and
spiraled out of control and created
demons one of the witches sisters
escaped and became the mother of
pyromancy her name was quelana and her
art was born of the chaos flame
she taught apprentices the art was
passed down and as a result the further
back you go with pyromancy the closer
you get to the more powerful the more
primal spells core NYX a Pyromancer we
met in the undead settlement tells us of
this if you seek pyromancy tones take
this sage advice
the lands of the lords converge upon
lothric the home of pyromancies drifts
comparatively close as well at least
that is what pyromancers of the Great
Swamp believe the place is calmed
izalith oh how I wish to behold a primal
pyromancy well these are old tales no
one knows where the truth begins or ends
he says that the lands of the lords
converge upon lothric and that izalith
drifts comparatively close as well so
just like characters and souls are
reborn and we see them again just as
time is convoluted and people are
shifting in and out are powerful places
somehow drawn closer to the land of the
lords when the flame fades as well could
this explain what Emma said about the
Lords of cinder you will not find the
Lords of cinder here they have left gone
to their journey homes converging at the
base of this castle within the central
ruins of the crucifiction woods is a
familiar figure
this crystal sage is one of two sages
that went on to ally with the undead
legion he did so to train the sorceress
of Ferren which explains the multitude
of undead sorcerers we just fought our
way through these sorcerers of ferren's
abyss watchers were known to be lonesome
warriors who would only rely upon more
pragmatic spells
phase two of the sage is ridiculous that
was probably the boss that I had the
most trouble with on my first playthru I
must have attempted it like five times
because all of these illusions shoot so
many spells and it's difficult to dodge
them and not get stun locked so my
advice for this is one do a lot of
strafing and sprinting and if you have a
heavy weapon just switch it out to a
fist and smack one of the illusions and
then move on to the next one and then
when you get to the real boss just smack
him into the ground a sorcerer with his
sanity does remain in the ruined cape
well this is unexpected I don't often
have visitors what do you want this is
my study that you've happened upon if
you haven't any business I've reading to
get back to how intriguing very well
indeed I am a sorcerer with plenty to
share however what champion demands
service without recompense clearly
you're not that sort of man so you will
make me a promise that in exchange for
my teaching he will bring me knowledge
in the form of Scrolls detailing sorcery
secrets well can you assure me of this
very well you're no fool I take it you
understand the weight of a promise
I am Orbach Ivan I'm unkennel Duan I
shall teach you sorceress we will learn
together and she'll be like our very own
school around him are hundreds of
valuable Scrolls the hard work of an
entire lifetime sorry I had to do that
as we return to filing shrine
yuria tells us about her growing concern
with orbeck all Bank of the name is a
cause of much consternation if left
alone he may one day in peril I rule
fall to this matter yearly else we are
unraveled till we meet again back again
I see I suppose this means your what is
this about it seems to too late then
there's only one thing to do with regret
I will end this here and now
but what
is that all I'm worth speak thy desire
honorable Lord of ours
ah I see or Beck's claim is proven false
as it should be our right and deserving
lord of hollows it is a long door
treasure befitting a true Lord Lord and
hollows may the dark sigil guide that
way let me know if you liked this
episode this one was much more focused
on the law but I could also focus more
on tips or items or little tricks that
I've learnt on my first playthrough so
let me know and I'll see you next time